you
hey everybody welcome to Vivaro this
project is going to require a much
lengthier introduction and just those
cup of cinematic shots and a few words
but in a nutshell this project is going
to be a steampunk floating island
console coaster which is a very weird
concept and I would say the project in
general is extremely weird and hard to
introduce because it's something that I
wasn't really planning to make up until
this point and it was definitely not
something that I felt obligated to make
a series out of especially since there
are already so many things that I sort
of feel the need to work on at this
point the thing is I just felt like I
wanted to make this thing not
necessarily because I wanted to make
videos of it but just because I wanted
to mess with this idea which has been
stuck in my mind for a couple of months
now and I realized that I have made it a
steampunk coaster before and I've made
quite a few castles in this game but I
haven't made something which is as
ridiculous and outlandish and
over-the-top as I am hoping to make this
thing because honestly a floating
steampunk castle island is something
that belongs more in strange concept
arts that never see the light of day
than any kind of theme park game
elements and that's precisely kind of
why I want to try it now one of the
things that kind of makes me wonder if
it's really that great of an idea to
start the series is that it's going to
be ridiculously into detail which is
either going to crush and fill or just
be extremely polarizing at best since
it's going to take an enormous amount of
work to actually get this to work so
this episode for instance has taken
about five to six hours counting the
time-lapse and the preparation I have
got way more in this time-lapse than I
normally would removing many pieces
which you've probably already seen that
I was cutting around here and there to
skip certain things that were built just
because the skill that this is built on
with this kind of level of detail is
perhaps too time-consuming even for the
time lapses and I wanted to at least
make sure that I get something done in
each and every episode which is why
we'll be skipping ahead quite a bit but
anyway it's going to be a crazy island
with a castle with a very steampunk
style to it I want to make very careful
with saying steampunk here since the
introduction as much as I wanted to go
for the cliche of having the camera go
through the cogs and gears of some kind
of machinery that'll be inside of this
enormous thing it's something that is
almost so stereotypical and not really
representative of steampunk that I want
to watch out for that kind of idea and
almost say that it's very steampunk
inspired because I don't listen to any
specific style or anything with this
project I just want to have pretty much
a whoa a free empty template to start
doing crazy ridiculous things on and
experiment in a sense that I haven't
really done so far it's going to be
similar in using elements to create
things that weren't really there before
but with all of the extremely small
pieces that have been added in the
recent edition of the game I wanted to
go much further with this than I have
done so far which to actually get to
wanna building at this point is probably
most visible in what I'm doing right
here I wanted to make the roof of the
top spire of what is going to be the
tallest tower in the entire complex and
I didn't want to take one of the in-game
roofs which would have been a pretty
easy way and I also didn't want to make
a custom roof which is just a simple
roof and instead what I went for is
almost kind of an Eiffel Tower thing
actually it's it's a lot like an Eiffel
Tower I I just call it the Eiffel Tower
roof it just sort of cut off the four
legs and I have a very small section
down there but that aside and it's
pretty much just the ironworks of many
Victorian pillars or bridge arches or
the Eiffel Tower so it's got that
openwork cost iron in there at least
that's what I figure it would be in the
shape of a very steep spire and
especially in some of the details like
having the
the golden elements and the very small
peaks of the spires I wanted to
experiment a bit with taking these very
small pieces putting them all together
in things that aren't really as
recognizable as in-game assets to just
add to the unique look of the entire
build and turn that into all of the
details and the same kind of goes for
the walls that I'm doing right here
since I didn't want to take one of the
in-game walls and instead I figured the
back of this weird scenery item sort of
looks like a sandstone wall and
especially if you put them over each
other and overlap them overlap them a
bit you get this idea that there are
very large sandstone bricks that make up
this wall instead of just the empty flat
back pieces on an item which you don't
even suppose the show and in this case I
kind of like the look it's a bit more
gritty it's a bit more textured and less
clean than many of the looks in the game
and I do want this to look like one area
what a dirty almost horror sort of
industrial steampunk look it's not going
to be all that clean actually happens to
watch a lot of cyberpunk stuff recently
so a bit of inspiration from that as
well with having all sorts of different
cables and duty pipes leading everywhere
but that's completely beside the point
basically I just wanted to make
everything in this project is
unrecognizable from the original
elements as I could and skipping ahead a
little bit here and this is going to be
the sort of middle part of the tower
just for force perspective reasons I
wanted to make the bottom part of the
tower a little bit thicker than the top
part and it's actually getting that
transition to work out right I had to
find some way to have a division between
the top and the bottom part so the the
function of that is pretty much going to
be this weird little thing with all of
the decorations all of the almost
freezes kind of things that sort of
split up the building into two parts
I'll have a bunch of windows and arches
in here it's not going to be anything
too special but a good way to just
divide the building into two sections
and you can kind of notice that it is
these two sections that it gives the
the tower and long slender but still
slightly thicker feeling on the bottom
of the tower and in that sense I was
quite happy with how this turned out
there's a bit of experimentation over
here as well with the side pipe pieces I
wasn't really very used to these pieces
I love the sci-fi theme I've just done
it quite a lot without the theme so I
wanted to avoid that for a little bit
but especially to get the more
technological look and the more steel
almost cyberpunk look into this build I
wanted to use some of the Syfy pieces
for some details so long as they could
actually have the same colors as the
rest of the building and not stick out
too much and for things like these
pillars but also any kind of random
machinery or details around the building
there is also some other sci-fi pieces
in there already
I think it works out quite well to give
it that almost otherworldly fantasy
feeling that it's not just simple
Victorian but it's it's really quite
ridiculous speaking of which I wanted to
add this weird little turrets on the
side of the tower which actually turned
into one of my favorite things in the
entire build it was not very
time-consuming it's one of the one of
the simplest things actually I just love
how it turned out it's it's very much
like the turrets that you'd see on the
Disneyland console on the side of the
towers or any kind of castle for that
matter but it's a bit more like almost a
rocket ship it's got that weird shape to
it and it's just suspended from the side
of the building in a sort of illogical
fantasy kind of sense that I would see
it as so it's just one large box with a
bunch of decorations on the top and
bottom of it that's really what it comes
down to so I wanted to mix all of these
different women pieces and different
like fountain pieces that you have
whatever really works intersect into
each other up to the point where they
almost become unrecognizable and sort of
just blend in with each other to create
all of these different textures and
shapes is what I ended up using for this
little Tower actually kept the middle
quite simple just put a window over that
a few very simple decorations and that
pretty much finishes that up it's mostly
in the bottom and the top of the tower
that I wanted to put all the decorations
and give that distinctly weird turret
like look to it which is not something
that you would really see in real life
but I'm quite happy with how it turned
out and finally the bottom parts kind of
comes out almost like how would we call
it again anyway one of the engines of
our other rockets almost and just
suspending that with a couple of simple
beams for a lot of these beams I end up
using wood even though I kind of would
love to have them look more metal just
because the wooden pieces are a smallest
the same goes for this roof over here by
the way which is also one of my favorite
things in this part of the build what I
wanted to do here was not really use the
in-game roof since we've seen that a lot
it's going to be extremely recognizable
and I wanted something that's a bit more
mysterious and less recognizable than
just using an in-game item now what I
did figure is that this item would
actually be very happy to give a
guideline on what to make a custom roof
look like so I ended up taking sort of
the profile of that and drawing a spiral
on it and filling in a spiral roof with
a square footprints on the side where I
left that now I did skip quite a bit of
this since this turned out to be one of
the most boring things to build ever
just rotating everyone in piece until it
fits just snugly between those two
wooden posts that spiral toward the
middle but actually works out pretty
well I didn't even practice this
beforehand it was just
Yolo let's try it and see where it ends
up and in the end I'm quite happy with
how it turned out it does have the
steampunky feeling in the colors of it
but it also has that strange
technological and completely useless
decoration to it so that pretty much
finishes up the spiral roof which is
going to be sort of the main tower on
the side of the main tower I'm probably
not going to be adding any more turrets
or towers on the side here as much as I
would love to add one more tower since
there's going to be a bunch of other
decorations this is not going to be
simply at this
cause what I do in this entire bill to
look a bit weirder and ridiculous than
that's besides I've already built plenty
of castles so I'm going to go into more
technological stuff and ridiculous stuff
later on that aren't necessarily
buildings but just to shape out what is
just going to be the most visual parts
of the entire building I wanted to have
this tower on the side to make the the
tower itself not look as boring and
simple anymore and again it's just a lot
of fun to take the different items and
put them into each other just see how it
looks every time I didn't really have
any kind of strict way that I wanted
this to look before hand which is what I
usually do usually I would actually
recommend it to have an idea of what you
want to go for before you build it
because it saves a lot of time it's one
of the best ways to come up with unique
and creative users of certain elements
but in this case I ended up doing the
exact opposite which I suppose works
because you're doing something
outlandish in something that would never
be built in real life and that's
supposed to be as more over-the-top as
you can make it so really there are no
rules to this it's just a lot of putting
different items into each other that you
feel could kind of work and then look at
it and either go yes that's okay I'll
keep it or go no that's terrible I'm
gonna have to remove that and usually
it's gonna be terrible when you have to
remove it but eventually you get those
like weird nuggets of amazingness where
it turns out that something works really
well like I actually felt with many of
the details of putting this building
right here together which are many items
that I never really put together in this
way but eventually it worked out very
well like this sign on the back that
gives those ironwork details on the
walls the different items that make up
the pillars of this building and
especially also the items that make up
the cornices some of them aren't even
really cornice pieces that I'm supposed
to be used this way but there are so
many things that you can just slap onto
a cornice and make into a pot with the
cornice and it's a lot of fun to mess
with that kind of thing
now what I also wanted to do is add some
balconies on the side of the tower
because so far the tower is just one
straight square footprints hour which if
you don't have anything on this side I
think it's just going to look very
boring just like a blocky building so I
wanted to have some things that really
jut out from the from the center of the
building and make it a bit more
interesting than just one large pillar
of rectangles so one thing that kind of
gives a bit of body to it is having this
large door which is an excuse to add a
huge balcony in front of it with all the
decorations and that should hopefully
even out the balance of the tower a
little bit more it also has these pretty
sweet lamps and I am still not actually
sure how those lamp like items they're
down in the window section there are
those couple of like hanger items and I
am still not actually sure how these
hangers are supposed to be used but they
can be used in so many different ways to
hang lanterns that it's it's pretty
funny I think every every way that you
can use them or every direction that you
can place them in works out pretty fine
so that's that and I just complete that
around to the other side because I
wasn't going to spend a ridiculous
amount of time on everything and now one
of the things that I wanted to do before
I moved on to making a coaster which is
going to run around this in the future
and doing a bit of terraforming is
experimenting a bit with the details
that I wanted to put on the side of this
building so far the the steampunk is
really just in the decorations that are
very Victorian inspired and have a well
stereotypical steampunk colour scheme to
it but I didn't really feature any of
the pipes or anything like that yet so
this was nice experimentation time to
mess with the different pipes in the
game there are a whole bunch of them in
a sense that there are only two pipes
that are strictly pipes but some of
these primitive art pieces like this one
can actually be used very well to put
pipes together some of the chimneys can
actually act as black iron pipes as I'm
doing over here as well and even if you
really need to you can use some wooden
posts or metal items to make some pipes
that come out of the sides of walls it
might not always be the most
realistic thing but it's definitely
something that I can work especially
with how small some of the pillar pieces
and primitive pieces are you can
definitely create the illusion of
whatever something is just by putting it
together in the right context now not
everything in this series is going to be
this meticulously detailed or
individually placed I would actually say
a lot of these parts that I'm placing
right now I would love to in the future
just copy around and copy paste s-- to
other buildings because honestly there
is no reason to completely remake and
recolor all of these pipes when you can
just reuse your old ones so further on
in the series I'm really hoping to have
a pretty fair amount of blueprints and
already make pieces of buildings that I
can just copy around and use as much as
I can because it's definitely that
functioning planet coaster which can
save a lot of time if you sort of blend
your builds well we know and actually
save all that stuff now if we're a very
short intimate so almost of building the
coaster itself I do have to say very
quickly this is not going to be mostly
about the coaster the coaster is an
intimate mega coaster but it's not
really all that relevant in this case
the coaster is more or less it's going
to be something that that creates the
entire build and something to explore
the build in but it's not going to be a
realistic coaster at all obviously we're
on an island so that's already - one
point for realism but also it's not
going to be an actual intimate based
coaster I'll make it safe for sure and
hopefully as fun as the layout as I can
with everything that I would personally
love in a coaster layouts and perhaps
some intimate stuff like having all of
the different s bends and zigzag parts
in there but so it's not going to be
based off of any real hyper coaster or
mega lights like the type should
probably be so the coaster is going to
be pretty strange as well it's not not
something that I'm really gonna put too
much focus in just wanted I wanted to
put that out there
and a bit of terraforming which is very
very rough not just in the literal sense
but also because I'm not really going to
detail this too much until it's done so
for now it's just going to be a base
that I know where everything is going to
be and how the bill is going to look
with all the buildings on top of it but
I'm hoping to do everything in this
build like alongside each other so I'll
be doing the terraforming alongside
making the buildings on top of it as
well as alongside the coastal layouts
I'm not going to make the coaster layout
and finish that before I go into the
scenery but I just want to make the
coastal layouts for the parts of scenery
that I am making at that point as well
which is a strange way of working and
also it's why I can't really show the
POV yet because there's not really much
to show that are so many things that
should be happening in the course at
some point in the future but it's just
the very start that I needed to get done
in order to actually get an idea of how
the coaster is going to run through this
area with the tower here so yeah that's
that's it's just gonna be very scenery
focused and here I just wanted to very
quickly come back to the tower on the
side here I didn't actually finish the
parts underneath this but I wanted to
get that done just get an idea of how
this tower would look in the future it's
gonna be quite a bit more busy than this
since I will have some towers on the
side that might carry the blades that
are gonna keep this entire island up in
the air yeah that aside it's not gonna
there's not gonna be anything attached
to this tower in a strict sense I'll
have some lower parts of the building
where it's a bit more bulky but there
are just going to be a lot of towers and
domes around the entire elements so
around the entire island so that's
something to kind of see it in in the
future which is why the tower in a sense
also looks a little bit off and a little
bit weird at this point in time because
it's just alone and it's supposed to be
in this enormous sea of like steampunk
towers and domes and everything now
finally I wanted to show a glimpse of
the cog which decorates the main tower
and it's the first supernatural element
which hopefully brings the entire
culture out of the simple course of
category and into something
a lot more fantastical anyway that's it
for today thank you guys for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next video
you
you